hi so here we are again at uh
this is session number three
and during lunch i thought of something
that i wanted to mention in session
number one and uh
and it's just a little bit of the my
personal feelings about how
what i hope the uh publishing this whole
program will
will achieve i learned programming
myself by reading
other people's software reading listings
of software
when i was a high cost student
and
some of the software i
was very good for me because it was
badly written and uh gave me a lot of
motivation that i i said this was
written by professional and uh i could
do better than that so i must be have a
special talent for it so i'm going to
major i'm going to become interested in
computers
and others of it was was very
beautifully written and i thought this
is a pleasure to read
um i i'd like to do something like that
someday
now i'm not sure which category this
particular program is going to fall into
but either way you seem to be winning
and you could reach the the right the
right person so i'm hoping that some
some people
uh young people who might see this
program and learn learn from it
at least one aspect of software writing
and i'm not sure exactly how
if this could be used in in curriculum
or if it or if it's just something that
people would would do during the summer
or you know to on their own to
to pick up but
somehow uh one of my goals has been to
to provide a uh
a picture of software here you know in a
way that might inspire some uh some
people out there to uh
to write uh to write their best software
now
the agenda for our afternoon
uh the next thing is uh called data
structures
for boxes and glue
and this is one of the key things that
that is used over and over in tech the
way
the way boxes lists of things are
are represented there
so
as i mentioned in the last lecture a
large part of the memory a large part of
the core memory that that's going on
while tech is running
more memory than in fact the whole
program itself
is
is um
this dynamic memory area this is where
we're going to store things about boxes
and glue
really
horizontal lists and vertical lists and
the elements of horizontal lists and
vertical lists can be
can include boxes glue and
a variety of other things
so now the uh
the first thing we have to understand is
is the way that memory array works and
um
and uh so step number one is is this is
to see that every item that you address
in the array
is
uh is what we call a memory word it's a
pascal record called memory word and
this is uh starting on it's in module
on page 37.
now a memory word
is
is something that it that uh
ought to be represented well by your
pascal compiler if you don't have a
pascal compiler that's going to do this
memory word correctly you can be wasting
an incredible amount of memory well a
factor of four
probably so
you'd like to have a pascal compiler
that packs things properly to a to a
memory word
now
when we when i have a something of type
memory word i it's a variant record the
the definition
is actually um
on page 38. so let's look at the at the
whole definition that's in module 108.
it's
where
let's see
might get it on the screen
so we have
a memory word is made up of four quarter
words this is one of the options or two
half words
and so we have a definition uh
there that says two choices uh four
choices this is just because of the way
pascal is i needed this particular type
but the memory word then is a packed
record
and it's uh and then it's a case for
choices of this in pascal means that
that there's four possibilities and uh
if you store something under under any
one of these you should retrieve it
under the same one
so if i set x dot int to something that
ought to be an integer then then i
shouldn't try to read out x dot
uh gr
i should if i'm unless unless i'm using
dirty pascal 30 pascal would allow me to
read out x dot gr
and this is called a variant record and
uh it's a special case of a record where
i don't store
the the particular variant some some
people uh would would put in there store
an integer one to four with the record
with with the with x telling what kind
it is but uh that was space and time and
and there's no point in it the way we
were using it so we have four choices
int gr hh and qqq
of four different types so this memory
word is suppose for all four different
types they're all supposed to come out
to be
approximately one word then of memory
and talk about these types in a little
bit there's actually fifth type that i
use in the program called sc and when
i'm and uh that's because i i also have
scaled quantities
this is a section that i didn't discuss
since the previous section of the
program
scaled quantity is an integer but it
doesn't represent an integer it
represents a a unit of uh
it represents a physical distance so it
has units and the units are scaled
points
uh
namely
um two uh two to the sixteenth scale
points makes one
point
that's uh
uh
scale point then is a so if a word is
scaled that means that the decimal point
is is uh 16 bits from the right hand
edge
and when i when
something is an integer but it's really
representing scaled i call it sc
instead of int
uh or i say that it's type is scaled
instead of integer
in order to
provide a comment to the reader about
that pascal never sees this but the
person reading this program gets to see
the difference between sc and integer um
now all of these um are supposed to take
up the same space
i worked it out so that tech will never
allow the user to to
give it an integer constant greater than
2 to the 31
minus 1.
so
or
less than negative of that so the so um
uh this means that that
tech should be able to work with 32-bit
integers that have signed
that have signs
um
and if you have a machine that has more
bits than that
well
um
you still run tech and those other bits
will presumably be zero
however
you could get actually larger integers
in there
through some arithmetic operations and
they just would overflow on machines
that are smaller but we we
would
prefer that people write tech programs
that are going to work on all on all the
32-bit machines
if you have a larger machine what you
should do with it is make your quarter
words and half words bigger so that
gives you a chance of making the mem
array bigger
then you can address more more words but
not actually work with bigger integers
or scaled values you don't really need
anything more any dimensions that large
inside a type setting job who's going to
uh
type set something more 19 feet
in one console so uh so we're we're uh
you know you know at least if you if you
wanted to you could probably break it
into two parts and and uh or or say that
it was
and or or magnify it up from something
else and have the magnification do done
in the dvi file so uh
so 32 bits is plenty for these integers
now glue ratio is the next case and that
is
something that you could define any way
you want to it's defined here as real
now a glue ratio
is uh is used
only to uh
when we when we're setting a box and we
have to stretch or shrink the glue then
the glue ratio is the proportion by
which the thing will stretch a shrink so
for stretching for example and the glue
ratio is 0.333 then
one third of the stretch component gets
gets added
and
it and
i distinguish between that and scaled
the scaled values are kept as integers
and the arithmetic is defined very
precisely
on all the scaled values because it's
important that every implementation of
tech compute exactly the same numbers
when it works with scale values scaled
values will affect the performance of
tech as far as how how many
lines get put onto a page
and
how many pages there will be in a
manuscript and so on if you stick with
the calculations as they're given here
you can be sure that you will get
the same type setting information on a
cdc machine as you would get on an ibm
machine
even though their arithmetic is done
quite differently they they at least
agree on integers but when you try to
tell them to do floating point
arithmetic you're liable to get all
kinds of different results
um and this would lead to different
types setting different pages and uh and
people's uh
uh sending
tech job from one place to another would
find that it that it doesn't work out so
this is a major change that i that that
i for
made in tech 82 that was at first it was
going to be the only major change
um but we felt quite strongly about it
as being one of the first uh first
noticeable defects in tech that we we
weren't machine dependent because we
were depending on floating point
arithmetic so i went to scaled
however for glue ratio it was a big pain
to to work with scaled numbers and
doing multiplication by by so many
ratios
which you had to do in simulating
multiple precision in order to get a
decent result in all the cases um and
really it wasn't necessary because the
result of a glue ratio never
participates upfront in text decision
making it only comes out when you're
setting the final uh
box in a uh
outputting to a dvi file does it
actually ever compute this uh this
number from the glue ratio so i so i can
i can
re uh use real arithmetic floating point
arithmetic in other words even though
it's
not um
it's not machine independent
um
because that's
that will only affect the positioning of
the final boxes in something that the
eye couldn't possibly detect
so um so you can use that there if you
want however to do fixed point uh
arithmetic instead of floating point for
example you're implementing this on some
kind of a micro that doesn't have
floating point
um
or it has horrible floating point
software
then uh there's a suggestion for how to
do glue all the computations you need
with glue ratio
in a
in something that would pack into a into
a word
um a 32-bit word and i wrote that up in
tugboat and that appeared in the uh
in i think the february issue of tugboat
i have a reference to it actually in the
program
somewhere
glue ratio
here it is
tugboat 3 1982 pages 10 to 27 it's the
reference on in module 104 so that's the
that's the that's the type glue ratio
which i've made real in this case now
if you change it to some other type then
you just need to find a few places where
i've used
glue ratios i have to print a glue ratio
i have to multiply by a glue ratio
and one or two other things
um and
and then you could you could substitute
something there that would be
probably better than a bad floating
point implementation if you if you had
to do it on a micro now on um
on
ibm pascal at least the way it was
some time ago
if you said real that would give you 64
bits
so you'd have to say short reel in order
to get a 32-bit floating point number
and um
uh you
person should be careful to uh declare
memory word so that
uh this will work out if
blue ratio was real and then integer
would be 32-bit but you'd still be
wasting 64 bits for every memory word
because the because it picks the the
worst case of these
what about two halves here's another
common common thing where we're going to
break up this word in pack two different
uh two two different things in the word
so two halves is defined up above that
and it's a packed record also uh that
has a rh which
you might realize is right half
and then the other part of it is either
lh another half word or two quarter
words
well rh is always a half word but
with an rh you don't necessarily have
an lh you might have two quarter words
b0 and b1
so that's uh the two halves type
and
and uh that two halves type is
is uh
uh quite commonly used
especially in well the whole upper part
of mem is is is entirely two halves as
we'll see now the the other possibility
is four quarters and that uh i think you
could guess it's b0 b1 b2 b3
um
all quarter words now
some machines
will pack a quarter word
if it goes in the range 0 to 255 say
and and if you have a 32 bit machine
you'll be able to get four quarter words
in one word
and they'll be treated as from zero to
but in other machines
uh the only type the only way they would
pack is if it was like minus 128 to plus
127.
what's happening here oh we're losing
we're losing the screen i think you
better leave that down because i might
get back to it again
um
it's fun to watch it isn't it um
so anna on a micro uh on a pascal
implementation that if you give it to
zero to 255 if it considers that a nine
bit
uh position then then you wouldn't be
able to put four of those in a word
and uh
on the other hand um on our pascal if
you ask if you say minus 128 to plus 127
it takes up a whole word for that
because it considers that a sign
position has to only go there so pascals
are quite different from each other and
i didn't want to make tech unusable just
for that fact so i was
so i defined quarter word
um in a in a very
general way
where
it's a sub range from min quarter word
to max quarter word
and uh
um and similarly half words go from min
halfway to max half word and you can
really find these
and uh chances are tech will still work
um now i'm going to have to debug it
with min quarter word non-zero to make
sure that i've not forgotten to add it
in the right place and subtract it in
the right place so what i do is if i
want to represent a number from 0 to 255
in a quarter word i subtract min quarter
word from it or no i add min quarter
word to it excuse me
and then when i read it out i subtract
min quarter word from it
now
the conditions that those constants have
to satisfy are all listed there in 106
so all the program is supposed to work
provided these conditions are true and
the program actually runs through and
checks those conditions
any tech does anyway checks these
conditions and gives you a
stop at the beginning saying uh sorry
but you set up your
uh you set this thing up wrong so that i
can't handle it the conditions are first
of all that
your
min quarter word has
to be
uh zero or negative you can't have min
quarter word equal to one because i'm
storing zero sometimes in a quarter word
okay
similarly max quarter word has to be
um
at least 127 because sometimes i'm
storing 127 in there
and uh okay min half word has to be
again zero or negative and the maximum
half word has to be at least uh
the largest 15-bit uh
number
then uh we also have to be have a
relation between quarter words and half
words that any quarter word can be
storable in a half word so that the next
line says that the minimum quarter word
has to be greater than or equal to
minimum half word and similarly for the
maxis
the next line says that the
memory base that's the lowest address in
memory
has to be
greater than or equal to a minimum half
word and the the largest address in
memory men max
has to be strictly less than max half
word these are the cases uh
uh the the relations here are not the
ones that must be true but the ones that
must be false
so max cannot be great or equal to max f
word the max half word itself is used as
a flag so the largest location
addressable in memory has to be strictly
less than your maximum half word so for
example if your min half word is minus 2
to the 15th
your max half word is 2 15 minus 1 is 32
767 then your mem max had better not be
any larger than 32 766
if you have a 36 bit machine you see you
could make your
max half word
to the 18th minus one and then you can
your memory max could be
four times as large as on a 32-bit
machine
similarly for fonts that uh so so the
gist of that line there i um says that
any memory address can fit in a half
word so i keep pointer data pointers to
memory locations in a half word
um
the next line uh says essentially that
any font
internal font number can fit in a
quarter word my internal font numbers
are the numbers that i that i assign to
fonts not the user's number but about
the one that tech that tech keeps the
user might have several fonts 10 11 and
12 that all turn out to to boil down to
exactly the same font and i'll map those
into the same number
inside so uh so i have an internal font
number and besides his numbers might
range from zero to a very high case but
i want to pack them all tightly so i so
i
um internally we have
numbers running from font base to font
max and those numbers internal font
numbers must all be representable in a
quarter word
uh the next thing is similarly things i
want to represent in the half word any
uh the save size that's usually very
small only a few hundred but i but but
uh if it were larger than a maximum half
word i'd be in trouble so i put all
those restrictions that would
conceivably ever cause tech any problem
i think i listed them here
and so they you're not allowed to have
more than um say uh
32k strings
now that's not
the size of the string pool that's the
size of the string start array that says
that you shouldn't have that many
strings well
um
it's rare to have uh
more than ten thousand strings who'd
want thirty thousand i mean because each
one of those strings would be pretty
long too so
so if you can't get that and a half
where you're in trouble i doubt if
anybody would ever set max strings that
high but if you did they would say bad
with 16 and later we get an error
message saying this is case 16 of what
you can't do
um
this error message is expected see these
error messages are expected to come
along so so rarely
uh and seen only by a person running any
any tech that they have just been left
as numeric codes
the last one is a buffer size your input
buffer which i have at 500 now and
that's been more than enough
um
if that gets larger than 32 000 then
that's bad
because i'm storing a buffer pointer
somewhere and a half word in at least
one place in tech okay so those are the
constraints there
and you want to design those so that
uh
so that it all gets packed together
now
uh i i
pascal compilers don't always optimize
adding zero and subtracting zero
and my program is careful to add min
quarter word
and subtract min mac subtract min
quarter word and half words and so on
especially this quarter word um
every time that i'm packing something
that might
might go past 127 into
a quarter word
and uh
um
well this is in the inner loop i mean
like every character go uh this happens
to every character
and so i'd be adding zero and
subtracting zero rather needlessly in
the part of tech that's supposed to run
real fast
if
i i believe the
but we've made memory counts before and
i think it'll still
happen in the new tech that
a small very small part of tech maybe
one percent or so is executed a large
number of times i and i'm and i call
that the inner loop and uh
we make pain so that that the inner loop
doesn't have a lot of wasted motion in
it
so because if the inner loop is fast i
can do just about anything everywhere
else and it won't make much difference
so
one of the things we're doing in the
inner loop is adding subtracting min
quarter word so i define macros for this
purpose there's the q i macro for into a
quarter word
and q o macro for out of a quarter word
and then just add and subtract min
quarter words this is in section 107
here you see
now
um
of course in my change file at uh sale
min quarter word is zero so i've just
redefined q i of hash to be hash
uh and uh because this pascal wouldn't
optimize the way that zero
and that'll save that'll make tech run
maybe five percent faster
so it's changing that one macro now now
if i haven't if i've missed it somewhere
in the pro in the program um
saying qi where i should have i won't
notice it right now because qi of
something is you know leaving it out
would have been the same so i'm gonna
run some tests where i where i have min
quarter word negative
and that means that my memory words are
going to not pack into one into one word
but that will be okay because i can run
tests on a small memory size
to check that but you won't have to
worry about i'll be the one that has to
worry about this this kind of testing
any questions on this part now do you
think you understand what a memory word
is um
yeah question yeah should we then this
uh please use the mic
should this piece of code then be
changed change those macros in other
words that that are compiled time
yeah in your in your change spot
yeah see i'll i'll i'll put that up on
the
i'll put that up on the screen let's uh
see if we can switch to the computer
file here and
i'll search for qi left bracket okay
here's the change that i made at sale
uh for this
and so you see that
with all changes to start the top line
is this is common to the two and then i
added this other sentence here so they
have been simplified here in the obvious
way and you see how i how i did it you
can you read the can can you read a web
source file instead of a web output file
is it sufficiently enough contrast there
you see you put up
at sign d for a definition
so that's the that's what you do okay
now um while i'm at this i guess i could
explain at the uh that i have a last
resort thing for for debugging
uh built into the into the tech debugger
and let me see if i can
activate that
um
let's see i'll run
i'll run a preloaded version of tech
this is
this is tech that's been pre-loaded with
a format
uh from
from the trip file
yesterday we we played around with the
trip file it has the pascal debugger in
it so i have to to do this to get out of
the pascal debugger
and now it's uh
it's running this tech and it says
format equals trip
82 725 which is probably last sunday
and uh
and now um to get into my debugger i
have a a
tech debugger built in also
that will do things in tech so
the tech debugger i can for example give
an undefined control sequence and it
will stop an undefined control sequence
now when i've compiled tech with the
debug switch uh debugging and
view bed or whatever that debug
backwards is if i
if i've not commented out the debug code
then i have a special secret option that
i can type
to an undefined control sequence however
i better get out of scroll mode before i
do that
because i'm in scroll mode that doesn't
allow me to
respond to undefined control sequence so
i go to error stop mode and give another
undefined control sequence now i got it
now i got a question mark prompt
um
and um
and so i can say d this is the secret
thing that i can do and that gets me
into my debugger now the debugger is
written at the very end of your program
it's module um
oh gosh
um
maybe not the very end but near the near
the very end yeah i see it here
page 3 95 96 module 1207 in 1208
and this is a cryptic thing that i use
only in emergencies but it gives me this
prompt of a hash mark
and it and then the numbered options
that i can type are described on page
396 and there are various things that i
can do
um
for example 11
uh we'll check the memory to see if all
the links are okay if there's any weak
links if there's a if the
lists have been clobbered somehow it
will uh it would have checked that well
it didn't find any problems
oh i guess they would like some of the
house lights in the audience
so that they can look at their own uh
copy
is it getting brighter out there can you
give can you give them some house lights
in the audience please
okay thanks now the
um
the option number one will print memory
word of
of the location n in memory
and uh well i should find a of a
location that's not zero let me just try
let me try five
580 and hope that it's not zero and see
what it is it's not been pre-know it's
been pre-loaded to zero
i should be let me well
0 to let's see
excuse me a sec here i'm going to um
uh what's going on
well
let's see
i'm going to try to find out which
locations are
are are not free
um so 527 to 570 are not free so i
should try i should be able to get 570
or something like that 527 so let me try
5 27.
um
okay so so if i say 1 and then 5 27 one
is my debugging command says print out
memory word 527 oh that's 0-2 done it
well
here's one that wasn't zero okay now
print memory word is something that i
can use that would print out a memory
word in all of its possible forms
so location memory location
is a memory word that can be interpreted
as an integer as minus 262 144 on this
particular machine
or if it's interpreted as a glue ratio
it would be minus 4.0
okay
and if it's inter no i'm sorry has a
scale if it's interpreted as a scale it
would be minus 4.0 because i divided by
two to the sixteenth if it's interpreted
as a as a glue ratio it would be zero
because it has a zero mantissa
essentially
now
the next line print out that memory word
as if it was
um
two halves and so to the left of the
semicolon it says 49152
equals 192 column zero so the left half
it's either an lh field in this two
halves it's either left half of 49 152
or it's a b zero of 192 and a b one is
zero
and the right half is six five five
three five can is that is that
sort of clear now if this word memory
word was packed two halves then the
right the rh part would be six five five
three five and with the two halves you
have either lh which would be 49 152 or
you have b0 and b1 which would have been
192 zero
and then the last thing on that second
line is 255 255 192 0. that's b0
b1 b2 b3
in case you call it four quarters
now this particular shows that this
particular pascal compiler
packs these words the one that i call
right half actually is in the left half
of the word
um
and uh the thing that i call b0 in the
case of in case two has is 192 but b
zero if it's four quarters is 255.
um
that's um
i think it's the left half anyway it
must be or it comes in somehow that way
so uh but it doesn't matter how the
pascal compiler does that um
since i'm never going to make any
assumptions about the way pascal does
the packing
i'm always going when i store something
in it with uh with two halves or if i
store something in the b0 field i'm
never going to read out an lh field
okay
i uh
but when i'm debugging i might want to
to take a look at memory and have it
printed out in this way
to see what it would be like in
different fields here's one of the
places then when i did dirty pascal this
is one of the few places in the code
where it does read a memory word in a
different format from the way it was
stored but i only use this as a last
resort i just built this in some so that
i could do so without having to do a lot
of
pencil and paper calculations
on the on the thing if i had to
otherwise i found it afterwards it
wasn't that
bad because if i go back if i type 0 now
i get back into pascal debugger and
pass golly bugger i could look i could
talk about mem 527
and i could say dot int and and this
debugger whoa 528 sorry
uh tells me what it is and then if i
wanted it uh with the
hh
rh
it would have given me six five five
three five and and uh i could also ask
for the dot qqq dot b
true field and it would have told me
what it is so i didn't really need this
print memory word very much
because i have it in the pascali butter
it does illustrate however the idea of a
memory word with a little bit of
redundancy so i think by now everybody
knows so much about memory words they
want me to move on to something else
right
okay
the format file that you dump out
uh
is all full of memory words so so the
the the format that contains all of your
strings your uh macros
font information
uh for quick pre-loading the dot fmt
file that is a file of memory word
that's one of the reasons why we
wouldn't expect it to be readable from
one machine to another
now inside that memory uh
well several uh arrays in the program
are of our type memory word but the big
one is this mem mem
and uh that's the one that goes from mem
base up to mem max inclusive
and
inside of that we do dynamic location up
until
a point called high mem base and that's
high man bass and low man bass and the
layout of memory is explained in modules
starting at 156
and then uh the next few pages after
that
the 156 gives really the layout of
memory that that's on page 51.
um
so
the uh the key
the the key place
there is high mem bass because memory is
divided once and for all into two areas
the uh the low part of it and the high
part of it and the high part of it is
used only for
uh one word records
and the lower part all is is used only
for records that are more than one word
long
now here again i didn't use pascal's uh
heap or something i programmed something
from scratch so that i could control
exactly how much memory uh was getting
used here and so that will be more
portable
now we and we could do a lot of other
things with it
same same kind of reasons as for strings
but even more so now
the
area uh
less than high mem then as i said is it
always has nodes of two words or more
um
and uh those above hymen are are done in
the simple one one word at a time
reservation
if you set if you have a job that has
lots of macros
macro
gets stored in one word
one word items the item actually
consists of uh the rh part is a link
and the lh part is divided into b0 by no
it's a lh part which is a token or a
16-bit representation of one token of
your macro definition so if you have a
if you uh are running something with
large macro packages you want a lot of
space above hymen base
the thing that put
in in the present uh the old version of
tech
the
thing that put big big demands on
uh things less than hymen base were
boxes and uh also uh the uh
the notes that were made up intermediate
to making paragraphs
for example when i ran this tech job on
sunday to print this this uh book for
you i got i overflowed my
memory below hyman base
when i got to the index and here i was
430 pages into this thing and it crashed
that memory capacity exceeded and the
reason was that there was uh uh
the word type had been used so often and
it came right at the end of a page so
tech memory was already fairly full
and then along came comes a paragraph
that sells all the places where i used
type in this program and it and for each
of those it built a very large
break node so that it could optimize the
the index entry for type
which was also a trivial optimization if
you looked at it because all the three
digit numbers there were five of them
fit on a line and there was nothing else
to do but to know this because it's
doing a fancy
ragged right margin and everything so um
um so the memory crashed because it was
overloaded there um
with uh with with boxes and and things
for the for the paragraph shape well
um
in tech 82 the paragraph
nodes uh are reduced in size from 10
words to three words and they aren't
generated as often so this that so you
won't need quite so much space there
however
if there are still
if you had an application that was doing
things with real long paragraphs there
you'd want there you would need a lot of
space below hyman base
but there's there's important reasons
for fixing it once and for all at
compile time what this timeline base is
as you'll see as you get into it so um
so this is the way uh
you have to make a decision
when you when you uh compile tech as to
what highman base is going to be
a heiman base is not listed in a list of
compile time constants in the module 11
because if you change heimim base at
compile time
then you can't run a format
you have to also change your fmt file
see the fmt file is going to start
loading macros at highman base
or and and compute some other some other
things that that go in to the to the
memory there
um
and uh but you you're allowed to change
mem max at compile time and it won't
affect your format file so if somebody
can so you can increase the size of the
memory up in the macro region up in up
in the upper area and just re just
change it in
in the constant section attack recompile
and you've got more memory up there
but if you're gonna if you have to
change uh high mem bass then you're
gonna have to also run any tech again
and uh and make another format file
the uh
the
process that you're not supposed to
change at compile time are listed in
module 12. so the constants in 11 are
given as pascal clnst type constants in
module 12
the uh
the the constants members and highman
base are defined as web macros
uh also hash size is another one that's
defined there
so if you want to change the size of the
hash table certainly uh you can't
preload your your
hash codes unless if you change the size
of the hash table many of the other
things though can be just changed and
the fmt file will still work even though
the size has been different so you can
increase the number of fonts you can
increase the number of parameters
increase the size of your buffer
increase the size of your string pool
most of those things can all be changed
without recompiling any tech
now that's the highman base then
separates the the dynamic variable size
memory from uh from the other part
now the the
variable size memory
starts out with a few words that are in
fixed locations
and i guess here i get to try out this
pad and see what happens
uh or should i should i try the
blackboard
i think the blackboard might be better
because everybody be able to so um
here's the dynamic memory and here's
your
here
i got you i got you okay i had better
light there but it's okay so here's your
dynamic memory this is mem
and
uh and uh i put mem base here
and mem max is a is the largest
and then there's high members somewhere
where you decide
um is a good place
if you compile with the stat option then
it tells you exactly what the maximum
amount of of memory you've used of both
kinds is
for each job and also within a
particular page so you can get a feeling
for what would be good for the kinds of
jobs you're running
now
there's another location defined in this
section on the memory
allocation
called first mem and second mam
and
these are where we actually do the
dynamic locations in between here we
have fixed locations set up set aside
for things that that i can refer to by
fixed addresses i know they they want to
be somewhere in them and i also know
that i'll always always need them there
so i always put them there so right here
for example we put the definition the
specifications for
glue that uh
like a fill glue or zero glue things
that that are that are people
um
can say when they say h fill and it will
refer to one of these words we know we
will always want an h fill to be present
in this area i have one word nodes that
i always want to be present these are
typically the heads of lists so that
they'll they'll be uh they'll have a
link field and uh and this will be
starting to point to to the first item
on a list
and and it's good to have another word
that starts that list you know it makes
a lot of the algorithms simpler so they
don't have to consider the empty case of
the special case so this is the highman
base to second mem
and
then all of these other from first mem
to hyman base this is 20 up to high man
base
and then this is about i don't know a
dozen locations in here all the way up
to mimex this is all dynamically
allocated
now the easiest thing to describe is how
we allocate memory in this part of in
this part of it all of these words are
of type two halves
um
remember the type two halves had an rh
part
and either b zero b one or h or lh in it
oh now the two so the two halves here
are um
uh the right uh the rh part is always
called link
and so typically our one word nodes will
be linked together in a list that we
that we uh
draw this way
in the link field i call it link and so
there's a definition that link is the
same as rh
now um
there's a pointer there's a there's a
global variable called
mem end
which tells the largest location in this
memory that you've ever that you've ever
seen that you've ever asked for so you
never so tech never bothers to
initialize this part of it this might be
gobs and gobs of memory just sit you
know it's nem end is the largest one you
ever needed
um
and it points to the and there's another
one called a veil
which points to the first one that's
that's not being used right now
so if a veil ever gets to to be uh empty
a null pointer then
we increase mem end
by one and uh and get the new location
otherwise we never look at memen
and if so but otherwise the veil is
pointing to two to one and that one is
pointing to the next one that's
available and so on a typical way of of
of keeping track of uh
of which things aren't currently in use
so when something is recycled instead of
doing a garbage collection we have a uh
algorithm that immediately makes it
available
and uh
uh
then when the veil becomes null then and
we need another one then we try to move
from m end at that time if mim n equals
min max we're out of luck we've run out
okay now
those algorithms then are described just
before the discussion of memory layout
uh
dynamic memory allocation starting at
module 110
that's right after the description of
memory words
and
in that section
uh it talks about the uh
the way veil is is is handled so let's
see that's the bottom of page 39
and um
and we
you might see my finger here a veil link
avail link of link of a veil these are
the available locations terminated by
null i never say 0
for a null link i always say no
and i defined no
to be
members
so it's the same as the address here of
the first word in memory which is turns
out to be also the same as
the uh
where zero glue is is stored i never
make use of these of this fact but it's
it's true
and in order to but when i say
null this means i'm thinking of it as a
null pointer if i say zero glue that
means i'm thinking of that as the
address where zero point plus zero point
minus zero point is stored
and um uh
if i say zero that means i'm not talking
about a memory address at all
in my program okay now
uh so global
for avail and mem end are defined at the
bottom of page 39 there
in module 113.
to get a new word um i say get a veil
and we have a function
says
that returns a pointer and the word
pointer is is is a synonym for half word
however it's only used when i intend it
to be a pointer into either mem or
one of text other big tables uh could
you show that on the screen possibly uh
here
is the get avail function
yeah your camera is pretty good
you get a veil function that
allocates a single word node and so
that's the simple algorithm that i
mentioned except that you see we have to
also always carry
uh uh
be careful of errors and so uh p is set
to avail if it's not null that's good
then we just set avail to link of a veil
now a veil is pointing to the next
available one
and we've reserved it otherwise
we look at mammond and we hope it's less
than mem max
going to virgin territory so if
if it's less than max that's great we
increase mem end and that's the value p
that we're going to get for this pointer
otherwise we call a procedure called
runaway now this is a procedure that
will come in and give an error message
saying do you have a runaway argument
because that's one of the most common
reasons for for running out of memory at
this point is if somebody forgot a right
brace and and it might be a parameter to
a long macro that doesn't have any
protection against
against right brace is missing and uh
here we would like that at least as long
as we're gonna gonna abort the job
for running out of memory we're gonna at
least want to point to where that where
the error was so it won't happen again
um
so so there's a runaway procedure that
will uh that will give a uh
essentially appropriate error message
there i believe then we we
we set link of p to no before we return
uh
get a veil whenever we get something
from that procedure it's going to uh
it's going to have its link field no
because
if you ever want it to be something you
want it to be null and you almost always
want it to be known when you're getting
a new word out of this memory
then there's something that would be
commented out unless we were maintaining
statistics and here's what would slow it
down because we have to get available
things rather often
so increasing this counter seeing how
many words are are currently in use
and uh
that and then
get a veil is um
the the value of the function is
is returned at this point
uh not to free a veil uh put something
again i just wrote a macro for it i
didn't want the procedure call overhead
particularly so
it was only needed about five places in
tech and so why not repeat the code each
time instead of calling a procedure so i
have free free avail of that pointer
um and uh so you just do the opposite
process we we put we plan a link field
to the previously available one avail
now points to the new newly available
one and we decrease the number of things
dynamically used there's no other way to
get available one word nodes you have to
call one you have to say get a veil or
free avail it's not allowed to do this
yourself and um okay come through the
next procedure is something that will
take a whole list and free them and free
them all up
now so that's simple in the one word
part of memory in the um in the variable
word part of memory there's a kind of
interesting method used
and i um i'll go to the blackboard again
switching this multimedia show here
does somebody have the time by the way i
want to try to pace myself
actually i have it on my screen here if
the computer isn't down
yeah 255 you're right
okay um
so in this area
of memory um
i'm sorry in this area of memory
the
um every time i i get a
a variable size
cluster of nodes
i make sure that i that the link field
in the first word is something unequal
to
um mem max
it's never equal to mem max remember the
mem mem we we never uh
i'm sorry never equal to max half word
because we made sure that mem max was
strictly less than max half word so this
uh this is uh something would never
occur as a link field or a pointer
if this was equal but the ones that are
available are going to be flagged by
having their first word in a link field
here as max halfward
um
now if islam so we can store any data
here except that one that one bad one
and then the rest of the format is
completely free
but going to
this is a in use
but if it's free
then we put max half word here
which i can just indicate by all ones or
something like that in binary
and
then we put the size here
of the free area
and then i have an link
an r link in the next word
and this is a this size a doubly linked
list of free cells that's that that goes
around in a circle
and then the rest of the words are are
unknown
now if i
want to free something
up i simply stamp its size field here i
have to know how big it is when i'm
freeing it and then i link it into the
circular list there's a list of all
these
of all these um
nodes
that are free
when i'm when i need to find a new place
in this memory
i go around this list
until i find one that's big enough by
looking at the size field
but before i check to see if it's if i
found a place big enough i i also look
at the one right after it to see if it's
also free if it's also free then it'll
have ones in this in this field here
and
then i can then i can
combine these two at that point and i
keep doing that until i get to a place
that's followed by a non-free one might
be preceded by a free one i don't care
i'll get to that one later if i if i if
if i really need it but i look ahead and
collapse it at this point um
and it and dynamically this this works
out very nicely and then i then i get a
uh
then i see if the size is right
if it's big enough that means that it
might fit perfectly then i can just
allocate it and take it out of its list
if it's if it's one too big
i can't do anything with it because i'm
not allowed nodes of size uh two of size
one in this area but so it has to be at
least two two larger if it's at least
two larger then
i allocate the top part and i decrease
the size of this one
so that's the algorithm that's explained
there in the next part for variable
uh for for getting variable size records
important thing to remember is if you're
implementing any extensions to it make
sure that you put some kind of a link
field or something in the first word
here that could never possibly be all
once that's a mild restriction but it
could certainly be violated if somebody
if somebody didn't know it
okay well
um now the uh uh
i'm running a little bit short though
because i wanted to tell you what goes
into these lists and uh
but i got i got through most of the main
ideas because
um
we talk about the info i i guess uh in
the one word section of memory i always
call the left hand
the lh part the info field and the right
rh part the link field
then
something that's also rather commonly
used in the program is an link in our
link field but these always refer to the
the info and link parts of the second
of the second word of a multi-word no so
if somebody if i ever in my program say
link i'm talking about the left-hand
part of of word two of of something
that's uh at least two words long
now all of these things that can go on
then in a horizontal list
are uh indicated uh
somehow and linked together and yeah so
if i have a list that has a hundred
items in it they're going i'm going to
have a pointer to the first one somehow
its link field will link to the second
one its link field will point to the
third and the final one will point to
null
i use a circular linking like this only
in the list of available cells for the
variable size memory
but the other lists are always uh
well there's only one or two exceptions
almost always end with no
and i have to tell what kind of uh
uh what kind of a thing i i uh what kind
of thing i'm doing
so um
there's a little bit of a problem
because i want to pack a link field in a
word and i also typically have a font
and a character font is 256
possibilities that's a quarter word a
character is 256 possibilities that's
another quarter word and my link is a
half word i've used up my 32 bits so
here we have a great solution due to uh
luis tarpado and inaki i don't know who
what combination of the two of you but
they
realized that just by looking at the
address of the word i could tell whether
it was in the one word part of memory or
the
or the variable part of memory so if
it's up in the one word part of memory i
know it's a character node
and i don't need to to look at it any
further i know that it that it
contains font and character information
so up here anything up above highman
bass is going to have a link in this
part and then it's going to have a font
and a character in its b0 and b1 parts
so it's called the font and character
fields
so as i'm going through a list i can
check to see whether the pointer is high
then i know that it's a font and
character
save the bit that way now
um if it's not then we have a type field
and so we have a type field and a
subtype field uh the type field tells
what kind of a thing it is is a box uh
horizontal made out of horizontal list
is a is it a kern or whatever the
subtype is a is further information
relating to the type
so
the type field then is something that we
have room for 256 different types i'm
only using about 30 of them
the subtype field is often not used at
all
if i was implementing this on a micro
computer i could
do something different about the
organization of the memory i um
since all these words up above highman
base are half words i could
allocate them as 16-bit as two 16-bit
arrays whose which go from high-man bass
up to mem max
and uh uh and then i could implement
from from members up to first memory
16-bit words
and make instead of a memory word i
could use
i could uh devise something so that i if
this would ever come out to a
some other number of bytes
then um i wouldn't i save a little bit
of space in here i don't think it would
save a great deal but it's a possibility
for changing you know is if you change
some of these macros you would be able
to
run the rest of tech just by changing
the way it refers to
nodes in memory um
with with some other memory
organizations that would be equivalent
however i don't think that in typical
use uh
you gain a great deal over over over
what we have
right now now each each type so i uh if
i'm looking at something in anything i
look at the t field it tells me what
type it is and uh the type
um
will be
one of these things listed starting on
on module 129
and there's just a great number of
definitions there
um
following all of the english language
words it says h list note is zero and so
the type field will be zero in such a
case
um
box node size is seven this is a
declared as a macro so that when i free
a box node if somebody chose another
way of storing this
and boxes were some other number of
words then
then you would only have to change this
macro in this one place uh the width
offset depth the this the second word of
a box node is its width as a scaled
number
that's defined here width of something
is mem of that plus width offset dot sc
okay that's the width of a box a depth
of a box height of a box shift amount of
a box these things are explained in
words above it
now the different things we can have is
our h list node v list node rule node
turn the page we get uh new we get uh
inst node insertion nodes mark nodes
adjustment nodes for the v adjust
operation ligature node
uh discretionary node
all of these have subfields that are
explained uh
what they uh what their
function is there i might go into that a
little more next hour
the what's it note i mentioned in the
lecture yesterday that's not type 8 and
that's for extensions in the subtype
you look at the subtype of what's it
node and it would tell you what kind of
a what's that you have
there's a math node that begins uh and
ends math formulas
glue nodes which are pointers to
to uh the actual specification of glue
current nodes and penalty nodes and some
more coming up later on set nodes and
things like that so the various
different types of nodes
and i describe this all in words uh as
to so that you know what they represent
in order to reinforce that whenever i in
this program whenever i define a
complicated data type i usually follow
that by a bunch of programs that print
out that data type in symbolic form
so at least you can you can get an idea
as to some programs that use this data
structure and how a safe way to refer to
the data structure is because if you're
going to have a program that's going to
print out what's in a node you've got to
be able to you know it's not only this
printout is not only explain what's in
the node but the program is going to use
the right uh protocols for accessing the
node so this whole section called
displaying boxes is really worth reading
when if you ever want to know what
what's in a
box we looked at one of those examples
before display a node p
it says if is char node and print font
interior so but if you look at these
codes you'll see that this is the way
you're supposed to
um to look at the data structure by
using the macros in this in these
routines that display boxes in blue and
so on
so so uh the the programs
not only uh uh will give printouts then
when you have to find out what's inside
of tech instead of sort of looking at
all those bits and and uh and checking
against the macro definition saying what
was type 3
not only does this
give you a program that does it
symbolically but it also uh the program
itself
shows you
as a paradigm of how to write other
programs that access the data structure
any questions on that before we
adjourn
okay thanks very much and i'll see you
at
in 24 minutes
you